the ps5 comes with an 825 gigabyte ssd
for storage
around 667 gigabytes of which is free
for you to use
which seems like a lot of free space
until you realize that games like call
of duty black ops cold war
can hit well over a hundred gigabytes if
you have the base game
warzone and all the multiplayer modes
installed oh
and you need to have ps5 games installed
on the internal drive
at the moment you can't expand your
internal storage but sony has stated
that ps5 owners will be able to
at some point in the future until then
here are some top tips to stop
you from running out of space one of the
crucial things you'll need to do with
your next gen console is keep an
eye on your available storage space it's
never fun purchasing a new game and then
discovering that you lack the open
storage to download it
every game you have in your library will
take up space in your console's ssd
and this also includes game disks that
will need to load data onto your drive
while you may have the urge to download
all your most wanted games at once
it's best to focus on the essentials you
will always have access to purchased
games in your account library so even
when you delete the game from your drive
you can still download it again
later if you want to revisit the game a
really solid tip though
is to turn off auto updates go into your
system settings and disable the auto
update feature
generally updates for your current set
of installed games will be downloaded
automatically
to your drive when your console is
online these include games you may have
finished or may not get back to anytime
soon
to optimize space be sure to switch this
off and focus on downloading updates for
games you want to play regularly
one interesting change that came with
the playstation's trophy system is that
the ps5 will now save a clip
of the exact moment you earn a trophy by
default the ps5 will automatically save
around a 15 second long video of
every trophy you unlock in a game this
innovation can be great for those who
want to save a particular moment
however these video files will add up
over time
resulting in a bulky media folder filled
with videos
of you earning all sorts of trophies
even the bronze ones
that didn't actually require that much
effort to save on space
we highly recommend disabling this
feature outright
if you do want to save a moment when you
earn a trophy then the ps5's create
button will allow you to save
video files capturing several minutes
from your recent gameplay session
so once something exciting happens just
tap the create button and the moment
will be saved
as a video it's always good to keep an
eye out for the growing size of your
media folder so every once in a while
it'll be a good idea to start clearing
out old videos that are taking up too
much space
the ps5 sophisticated ssd is an
impressive storage device and it also
shows off the speed
in next-gen loading times you may be
tempted to load everything onto the ssd
but like i mentioned earlier
you can't put ps5 games on there so a
better option is to use your external
storage device
solely for backwards compatible games
plugged in through a usb you can
download your ps4 games
straight onto that external device and
play them from there
your load times may be a little bit
slower because you're using an external
device but
think of all the space you'll be saving
the ps5 lineup includes a set of games
that are available for the playstation 4
as well
along with letting ps4 users experience
some of the latest games
these cross-gen titles also allow
players to carry their progress to the
ps5
however a surprising quirk that comes
from this is that it's possible to
download ps4
and ps5 versions of the same game
simultaneously
on your next gen console to avoid this
from happening to you
download the games you purchased
straight from your library instead
in order to make sure you have the
proper game downloaded and set
highlight the game on the cross media
bar and hit the options button on your
controller
to bring up a sub menu select the game
version option to see the list of
available versions for the game you have
installed and select the ps5 edition
even after installing the ps5 version
the media bar can sometimes default to
the ps4 version
prompting you to download that before
proceeding with the game so make sure
you have the ps5 version set and let's
hope that sony fixes this issue
soon we've got so much more about the
playstation 5 including graphics
comparisons
loading comparisons and even hidden
features on the console that you may not
know about
so make sure to check out gamespot.com
and youtube.com
[Music]
gamespot
you